voters in Kuwait are preparing to cast
their ballots in the second
parliamentary election in less than a
year Kuwait is the only Gulf State with
an elected assembly that has the power
to challenge the unelected government
however disputes between MPS and the
cabinet have led to a political deadlock
al-shazira's Rob Matheson is in Kuwait
City so Rob you've been educating me on
Kuwaiti politics and the country has
held three general elections in just
over two years why is that number so
high
normally when we talk about elections in
Al Jazeera we're talking about big
issues like economies or big industrial
projects or social issues this time
Kuwait has all those problems but it's
not talking about any of them or at
least the the Parliament and the
government aren't because they have been
essentially deadlocked for the past two
and a half years now there are a couple
of reasons for that there's many to do
with the structure of the parliament
itself the parliament has a tremendous
amount of authority because of the 1962
constitution of Kuwait which is a very
unusual in the Gulf it's a very unusual
state for any parliament in the in the
Gulf to have quite as much power as this
one does in Kuwait
the second thing is that there are 50
seats out of these 65 seats in the
parliament which are essentially up for
grabs they're electable seats which
means that candidates can can go through
campaigns in order to get voted into
those seats but there are no political
parties which means you've got a
parliament with 50 people all
independence all with their own opinions
all determined to do their own right by
their their constituents but who are
also determined to make their position
work for them essentially that has meant
everything has grown to a halt as far as
kuwaitis are concerned it's a little bit
like Kuwait on a Monday night there's a
lot of Bluster and hot air but actually
you get very little out of it and
kuwaitis are getting very very tired of
continually having their parliaments
dissolved and more elections and we're
going to be covering those elections
which are happening on Tuesday here in
Kuwait but we've been finding out a
little bit more about all of this
for the second time in 11 months voters
in Kuwait are hoping to break the
deadlock which has paralyzed their
government for more than two years
analysts say one of the challenges is
that there are no political parties and
candidates run as Independents Kuwait
almost had its official Constitution for
70 years
woman had the right to vote
almost 18 years
but we still don't have any political
parties
we are relying heavily on individuals
who we think are good enough to
represent us there is not enough focus
on teamwork
voters choose 50 of the 65 seats in
Parliament the Amira points up to 16
cabinet members 15 of whom have seats in
the National Assembly since 2020 the
assembly has been increasingly dominated
by members opposed to the government to
try to break the impasse in 2022 the
Crown Prince issued a Royal Decree to
dissolve parliament and kuwaitis went
back to The Ballot Box in September but
six months later the Constitutional
Court ruled that decree invalid saying
it went against the 1962 Constitution
which gives significant power to
Parliament the court ordered the
National Assembly be dissolved and
replaced by the one elected in 2020.
then in April Crown Prince special or
Saba announced Parliament would be
disbanded for a second time sending
kuwaitis back to the polls there is a
feeling of
lack of Interest even many politicians
running for elections decided not to
have permanent
campaign headquarters we have to also
realize
what saves our democracy is for us
to practice our democracy on the streets
there's little sign of active
campaigning
kuwaitis have told us that they're no
longer interested in politics or that
they just don't feel that it's going to
need relevance for them anymore but some
have been saying that they're very
concerned that unless the National
Assembly can get some sort of consensus
then Kuwait's politics will continue to
be deadlocked and Parliament could be
dissolved once again
Kuwaiti say politicians need to start
talking about the future of their
country but they're not holding out much
hope Rob Matheson Al Jazeera Kuwait City
well we're going to be watching uh
tomorrow when we're covering the
elections for Al Jazeera in here in
Kuwait on Tuesday is going to be the
turnout there are 793
000 registered voters out of a
population of 1 million local media is
speculating there may be between 50 and
60 of a turnout would you give an
indication of just how disinterested
people have become in these elections
interestingly candidates too are also
becoming more disinterested last year
307 candidates for 50 places in
September in those elections this year
207 for those 50 places rob you will be
heading our coverage of Kuwait selection
uh tomorrow on Tuesday separately I
enjoyed your earlier analogy between
Kuwaiti politics and the weather so keep
them coming thank you Rob